what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off bruce fenton is a
dedicated scholar of anomalous phenomena
focused on revealing the origins of Homo
sapiens in this conversation we discuss
what anomalous phenomena is the history
of meteor impacts on earth why
geomagnetic reversals are important the
evolution of Homo sapiens Bruce's theory
on why extraterrestrial forces came to
earth on an artificial intelligence
probe how all of this relates to CRISPR
technology and how the media and others
should be encouraging scientific
experimentation I fully recognized that
many of these are radical ideas I think
it's important to hear all perspectives
and expand our understanding and
learning I won't do many of these types
of episodes but when I do they'll be due
to a personal curiosity and I'll do my
best to make them informative and
entertaining I really enjoyed this
conversation with Bruce and I hope you
do as well skirt school want to know who
has the best URL crypto comm that's
right crypto comm they're a crypto
platform with one goal motherf and mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto calm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out tell
them pump sent you download the app or
visit crypto comm Tom Scott you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy Pomp's
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a PlayStation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide
and then you receive over-the-air
updates that add new coins and new
features on a consistent basis kind of
like how Tesla does over-the-air updates
and updates the car software just you're
updating your coin mind consumer mining
made easy that's right
go to coin mine com tell them pom sent
you and thank me later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long-term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by interest account users
can now securely store their Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
6% is an absurdly high rate it's the
best rate in the industry I highly
suggest you go check out block Viacom /
pop again that's block 5 com / pop to
sign up and start earning crypto today
Anthony pomp leon o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang-bang I am super
excited to record this episode we've got
Bruce Fenton here with us
Bruce is is been spending a lot of time
focused on many things around human
origin and extraterrestrial involvement
along with other scientific pursuits so
thanks so much for taking the time to
come out and record this Bruce I find
he's an absolute pleasure we're glad to
be here for sure so before we kind of
get into the fun stuff I want to just
start with your early life and your kind
of your childhood and your background so
that when we talk about some of your
work today people have an understanding
of the perspective that you're coming at
this from where were you born kind of
what was your early childhood like sure
I'm from a small town in the South West
of England cool
crowd which is a rural town and
basically you know Claire backwater
place not much happens but I went to an
English boys grammar school I come from
that that kind of I spoke back once with
middle class English background product
of the system so socially recognized the
the kind of the accent I have a bit of
the Queen's English tone to my voice and
really I've got into these kind of
obscure topics I suppose young I mean I
had a grandmother he used to give me
these collectible cards that there were
small collectible cards will come with
her tea leaves and the matron would have
like a mystery you know like the
pyramids or crystal skulls you know all
those kind of strange classical strange
stuff and I just found them I just found
them really fascinating to be honest I
suppose as as time went on you know I've
gotten to read in those topics and
that's where it developed from got it
and and so as you kind of went through
school and everything was there anything
that you did in terms of like research
or was it really more just personal
curiosity and entertainment to some
degree yeah nature was more of just you
know a bit of a hobby I suppose from
pulling on a 20-ish then I became a bit
more serious about it as a research you
know area and would you know to get more
technical books on topics like you know
ancient civilizations and also some of
the the like a psychic or topics
paranormal all of these subjects you
know obviously there's a university
X just high emulator you're not you're
not really weighed down with work and
family so I mean I mean I at the time to
have this as a kind of a side project
there are sad experiences of my own I
had a number of strange kind of
psychical experiences you know because
of telepathy knowing what people's
thinking and doing memory in people's
names you know they owed me in a club
and I would tell them their name you
know to total strangers so those are the
kind of events of course that then
intrigue years - well if it can happen
to me then he must be having to other
people there must be a valid phenomenon
here that's worth studying so so it
wasn't just because I found intriguing
you know an exterior
he was also personally rather than for
sure and then where did you go to
college and kind of what was the the
focus of your collegiate or university
study I went I better study at ITT
actually in East Anglia which is east of
London if people know the UK a little
bit it was a Anglia Ruskin University so
I did a information that has to need an
information systems to go into a high
national diploma and that went into
after that was working in banking and
some IT roles and stuff in the city but
alongside that yeah maintained an
interest in really all things mysterious
you know that the full gamut from
shamanic topics to courses we covered
some of the extra-terrestrial lost
civilization it really started to you
know it starts to snowball you find that
most these topics they'll even get into
each other so inevitably if you if you
explore one of them at any depth you
start to encounter all the others right
so it immediately becomes quite a web of
subjects for sure and in today
you know I saw in mine that you describe
yourself as a dedicated scholar of
anomalous phenomena and really focus on
kind of revealing the origin of Homo
sapiens but before we get into kind of
second piece just talk to me about like
what exactly is anomalous phenomena and
and there's a whole kind of scientific
community and body of work here but from
your seat like what exactly is that work
Penal Code most all areas of science
today you know the within the existing
coupla consensus theories you'll find
anomalies you know these these little
bits of data that don't fit the theory
and that has yet not been resolved by
further research further experiments you
know so of course in the respect to say
ancient history and human origins if we
have a number of anomalies and that's
partly because of a lack of data you
know the further back you go it becomes
very hard to to get the evidence that's
right but but even you know physics we
narrow seas for example there's been a
few events lately and I'm a pretty go
into with some craft that have been
observed that seemed to do
the laws of physics now we'd say these
anomalous because they suddenly stop and
then they can suddenly you know they
appear to be instantaneously at maximum
speed again that would be a normally
because we understand whitcross have to
slow down and speed up so again there's
physics anomalies and their biological
anomalies I'm interested in all these
all of these really to some degree and
not see only in certain areas I have
special skills which allow me to resolve
some of them or attempt to resolve
someone so that's my focus is really on
the normalness science because of the
SPR the Society for psychical research
and they deal with anomalous phenomena
and probably more famous organizations
that they research the paranormal and
psychical type claims you know and
they'll apply scientific rigor to do
testing these claims to see if they can
find you know in a real real tangible
solution for why certain things seem to
happen which we don't fully understand
for sure and I think that you know for
those at home who are unfamiliar with
this you know when we talk about that
scientific rigor and some of the
associations and things like that you
know there's I think probably one of the
larger ones is the associate the
Association for the scientific study of
anomalous phenomena that's you know
found in the eighties right in the UK
and studies everything from ghosts to
circles
aliens UFOs kind of all of these things
that I think have entered into the
mainstream culture in more kind of
mimicked type or comedy right because
it's kind of like the jokes and kind of
personal curiosity but no one would ever
openly admit in a traditional
professional corporate environment hey
you know I believe in ghosts I believe
in aliens you know it's kind of taboo a
little bit but there's always you know
some form of truth in this stuff and I
think that you know it's important for
people to really understand that there's
an entire community of academics of
researchers and scientists who are
dedicated to studying this stuff of
which you are really attacking kind of a
a subset of that
work absolutely and really there should
be no area of human experience or human
origin which is beyond the remit of
scientific investigation so I think it's
a sad fact that we ever developed this
kind of you know Fran circle kind of
joke approach to certain areas of human
spirit because you know if hundreds of
thousands of people report seeing a
ghost or report and seeing aliens or
whatever it is you know there's a valid
phenomena for scientific research right
no matter what the final conclusion of
that research is even if it's that we
have a mass delusion because the mass
delusion would be a fascinating
discovery right that there's a hundred
thousand people suffering from some rare
brain condition that causes them to see
the ghost of you know I know King Henry
the eighth's right that that would be an
astonishing scientific conclusion
wouldn't it for sure and you know look
I've been pretty clear with with folks
that you know my personal interest in a
lot of this work and and and really kind
of around this idea of intellectual life
outside of Earth comes down to the idea
that science is supposed to be
experimental right there should be no
sacred cows the idea of forming and I
hypothesis putting it through that
scientific rigor and being comfortable
coming out on the other end with
whatever facts and conclusions are there
right so not saying I'm going to reject
science but saying instead I have a
thesis that I'm willing to put through
scientific rigor and when I come out the
other end I'm open-minded as to what
that conclusion can be based on those
facts and I think when it comes to kind
of you know extraterrestrial
intelligence and life and you know the
UFOs I got all of this stuff that I'll
just call you know kind of outside of
Earth I think that there's a lot of
people who don't have that
open-mindedness right but but as a
friend recently told me you know look
one of the greatest scientific
breakthroughs that we could have in our
lifetime would be the discovery of in
life outside of Earth right I mean that
is a an inflection point in both the
Homo sapiens on earth but also in the
trajectory right if all of a sudden we
know that there are other people out
there we can confirm that we know where
they are
etc I think that it really would not
only expand the thinking of people but
but it would change the way that we do
things or think about things and plan
which would obviously be pretty pretty
serious stuff yeah absolutely I mean
it's it could really write these or the
software of the brain and way that the
way we think about ourselves the way we
think about the future of our planet the
way we'd go about certain areas of
infrastructure would change you know but
just know that we are not alone and that
there's weather already or potential to
connect with other intelligences you
know yeah I think would be an enormous
rewrite for a lot of our thinking we
perhaps probably the two biggest
questions out then interests in science
and philosophy other you know
does any element of us survive death and
are we alone in the universe I mean
there's there's not many other questions
that are on par with those right I mean
you know we all at some point will
probably ask those two questions for
sure and I think there are the way I see
it is that both of those questions are
really important everyone does ask them
at some point and most people have a
foregone conclusion or assumption in
their head
right so they you believe that there is
some afterlife where they don't and they
either believe that it's likely that
there's other intelligent life or they
don't but but I don't think that those
assumptions disqualify the importance of
the scientific rigor to actually get
confidence in a conclusion right to be
able to confirm yes there is an
afterlife or there is other life out
there outside of Earth again it produces
a level of of competence and kind of
finite answers that that again change
the behavior and understanding that
humans have today I'm so moving I want
to between there I was really in the
icing the stories of the tech world as
well as that
so if you know that there is something
out there which is possible that you
can't do that right but you know saying
a competitor can do something or you see
a technology right which is being used
another nation you don't know you know
it's possible to develop it right so so
suddenly if you have a team work on it
that I really really creates by the fact
that hey something else can do that then
we can do that right so if we know that
there is intelligence out there and what
we detect them and we start to learn
something about them we find that they
have let's say certain technologies
certain knowledge of science and we say
hey that that's really a radical rethink
of what we assumed you know what we
thought was possible and that it's going
to really change how we go about
developing new technologies right
because if we know civilization X can
create such and such a machine then we
can right but so so I think we're gonna
write a CD that happened it not only can
know establish there is something there
and they have things technology that
that would really change the way we go
about developing future tech and things
like that so it could I think it's got
an amazing impact and of course I'm
underlying this we're go to curves yeah
I'm liking that that that is a current
virtual world situation like that they
have evidence that we have evidence that
these kind of things are one that there
is intelligence right if we look at some
of the things that are happening at the
moment of course we have recent events
you know suggested technologies
operating right you know you know
atmosphere which do 2phi some more
understandings now with their extra
stroll or whether they are some unknown
you know operator those are going to
inspire people to replicate right we're
going to have these these tic-tac things
whether they're being caught people are
going to look at those and say we're hey
you know how do we stop her you know
immediately and then certainly change
which I'm sure that's already happening
which was you know that's been worked on
probably since the first detection right
so if there's ways of studying other
elements of that technology now assuming
is again probably not human-made then
we're about to - you know start to chase
whoever it is that's doing this and try
to do catch up you know start to develop
some really astonishing things
yeah and we're really talking about it
it's kind of like the Roger Bannister
effect right that no human had ever run
a four-minute mile
all of a sudden Roger Bannister runs the
four-minute mile and you know within you
know 1 or 2 years it was like 20 people
yeah right and it was the belief that
hey this is possible another human has
done this kind of you know broke open
the floodgates with you oh yeah
absolutely no I've heard of experiments
where they've done this where they've
had teams of scientists have been given
almost like you know a fake video of
something to show them that is possible
and that has changed the belief set of
the team right because it's like look
somewhere else to do it then you can and
anything all right yeah we must be able
to you know where's beforehand they
would have assumed it was impossible and
they've gone on to develop that oK we've
this specific case but I regret that but
obviously again it you know it does seem
that you're able to to change people's
thinking and I mean that seamless blue
anything right we'll say if you can see
something else happening well they're
gonna believe it misses that why we're
seeing now of course a change in what's
been called the UFO subject that we're
seeing things that now people are forced
to rethink a lot of assumptions and I'm
gonna go a bit into that should we talk
a little bit about the recent videos go
into detail with that or for sure yeah
so what let's before we get there what I
want to talk about is let's go kind of
chronologically from where I'll call the
beginning of time right but really what
that is is pre-human right there were
pretty well confirmed pretty well
accepted
dinosaur life on earth right and this is
a whole host of various types of
creatures many of them that don't exist
today and the first kind of thing I want
to talk about is this idea that there is
one theory that is pretty well accepted
that there was a meteor strike into
earth you know some estimate that it was
as much as 65 million years ago right so
so we're talking the incredibly long
time ago and that meteor strike hit
and a very big piece of it hit in the
Yucatan which is in Mexico and when that
happened it basically created such an
impact that there was a bunch of fire
and dust that was able to block the Sun
from actually getting into kind of crust
of the earth right are actually hitting
earth and in the way that we think about
it and due to that blockage of the Sun
there was a drastic cooling of
temperatures on earth and then that
ultimately led to the extinction of
dinosaurs because they just couldn't
survive and that climate you know one
just are you on the side of hey that is
valid are you on some other theory there
and then talk to me a little bit about
the science and the understanding around
just mechanism of a meteor impacting the
earth and kind of you know we'll use
that to them get into some of the other
work that that comes in in more recent
times yeah I'm definitely a specifically
a cataclysm proponent in the you know
for a long time geologists and rafi
biologists have no keen on Cataclysm as
drivers in science I mean historically
there was a lot of rejection of the idea
that calf isn't play a huge role in the
story of life that we know today that
they do we know that there's been mega
events as you said like the dinosaurs
were essentially eradicated for most of
them they're setting a larger dinosaurs
and the remnants were forever changed
you know we have I've seen these species
that arise from but the large dinosaurs
essentially died off and the mammal age
really began because of that so without
an event like that you know would
mammals have got their foothold you know
would we have started on the path to to
humanity probably not you know we may
have later on with the help of a
different Cataclysm but without the
removal of the top dog the dinosaurs
it's hard to see that we would have ever
developed right so we can see in the
poorly cataclysms and you can go back
further than we have those we have like
now there's the great dying this one
no longer moved in the way they do today
so the oxygen levels changed we've had
all these different kinds of problems
with big huge die offs those it
absolutely shaped you know the in the
environment for us and it allowed for
our development so yeah I'm definitely
I'm on board without that these
cataclysms were worth knowing even a
valid Maria but hugely important to our
story even though they some of them
occurred hundreds of million years ago
you know that they still have shaped the
world to where we are now and allowed us
to become if you want you know at least
for now the sort of top dog for sure and
in in terms of the meteor impact this
really is for those that have no
scientific understanding or haven't
looked at at all it's really just the
idea that there are rocks or debris that
are floating around in space and it's a
collision right they're simply they're
on a trajectory that ends up
intersecting with the earth and it is
able to make it through the atmospheric
kind of pressures and in chemistry and
ultimately strikes the crust of the
earth right is that a fair way to kind
of describe what's going on with those
meteor impacts yeah absolutely yeah
we've got a lot of debris out there
that's orbiting the Sun as we are at
various distances obviously we have the
Oort cloud much further out but we have
the asteroid belt which is nearer to us
so some early means these objects will
come into the inner solar system at
times we have caused comets as well a
long large or elliptical orbits but this
is all material that's within our solar
system and it's all essentially orbiting
the Sun so yeah every now and again
you're one of these objects will just
cross with us or you'll be moved by the
you know come closer to the gravity of
seeing the larger planets like me or
Jupiter and just stabilize an orbit and
that will end up with an impact event
but we know that roughly every thousand
years was just in a a fairly significant
stride but you know it's every hundred
thousand years or so that we get you
know I guess a really large maybe a mile
across kind of chunk possibly coming
into this those are you know seeing much
or irregular the smaller chunkier we do
you know every thousand years or so
against an average will get something
that will you know could take a camera
you know could take a turn out or
something you know that you if it landed
in the wrong place for sure and so there
are some very well-known be your strikes
obviously like the the one in the
Yucatan but then there are ones that are
only recently either being discovered or
less popular you know before we start
when we were talking about one that was
discovered in Antarctica right and it's
this idea that these researchers from
Heidelberg University were able to
gather these tektites takes it and they
were able to find these in a whole bunch
of different continents but ultimately
there is this massive meteor that
appears to have struck earth and
specifically in Antarctica region that
created an impact similar to that of
which you know ultimately killed off the
the dinosaurs
yeah that's right I mean as part of my
current research project I was four
reasons will come to I was focused on a
period around seven hundred eighty
thousand years ago and it turns out that
there was extensive widespread
destruction from a number of impacts
asteroid impacts at that time that
you've got at least when they hit the
Americas another one in in Africa
another Dino she a Nia Tasmania and yeah
this really big one which hit Antarctica
which you know one of the creator's from
from that trunk is two hundred miles by
two hundred miles so many people imagine
the scale of that so we're talking about
a global bombardment absolutely
devastating effects that you would have
had you know extreme powerful tornado
tsunamis and obviously also earthquakes
you have just thrown up into the
atmosphere which causes cooling what
they think is the impact the effects
were lessened by the fact that it was an
ice age at the time so for example you
know the hits that in anti to actually
went that into the ice it did melt quite
a lot of you know war
they rose to see levels but fickle
tsunamis are drastically reduced right
by the amount of sea ice you've got so
there was there were some factors that
you could say aloud life to weather this
storm better than during the impact that
wiped out most of the dinosaurs so you
could say we were kind of fortunate in a
way that this was happening during an
ice age and not at any other period got
it and so explain a little bit more this
idea that the tsunamis can be reduced by
an increase in ice it's just literally
taking the the liquid and putting it
into a more kind of ice structure and
that means that there's less water for
Nami the energy is going to be
dissipated into the huge chunks of ice I
mean you know the sea ice as well
covering huge amount of the ocean a lot
of your energy that would normally go
into the way this being is being
dissipated into that ice as it as it
radiates out if you imagine this kind of
this wave obviously it's it's connecting
with ice you know so it's losing energy
into the ice so I'm like well if you've
just got the notion that wave moves you
know fairly freewheeling and it's still
losing energy as it goes but not to the
degree
we've got enormous stretches of ice out
there and icebergs and so this can be
hitting all of this solid materials it
goes and dissipating energy so really in
that respect it was looking wouldn't
have ended up
perhaps with these kind if you know
kilometer high waves coming inland and
wiping out you know entire vast regions
it would have been significantly reduced
I mean the the impact I suppose you
would have literally had like waves that
were you know a community kilometers
high I mean I may be under exaggerating
it I know that they were certainly
enormous waves once they came onto land
the kind of energy you're dealing with
with an object say 2 3 miles across
anything is just it's just a sterling
you know it's a meant waves that go
around the world you know multiple times
so it's sonic booms like around the
world multiple times fire storms of
course you get the dose of dust that's
thrown up you go simply a nuclear winter
I mean it it's sort of boggles the mind
to imagine the level of destruction that
you're talking about and there may be
other secondary effects which also
turned up in my research is that it's
possible that some of these impacts
actually initiate ones like magnetic
reversals and another unexpected
phenomenon that comes out of them right
so they're really really you know
disturbing for the ecosystem yeah so you
just mentioned it so let's go talk about
the the geomagnetic reversals um I know
nothing about this so just kind of
describe like what exactly is we say
geomagnetic what is that and then what
is the the idea of a geomagnetic
reversal sure I mean the plan I'm
standing is that due to the movement of
molten iron in the core of our planet
and also molten lava the movement of
this material according electromagnetic
fields so this was like a dynamo effect
that the earth is constantly generating
and regenerating it's its own
electromagnetic fields now lose extend
down to space and they have they have a
kind of beneficial effect in some ways
they do block some of the the cosmic
energies that would come into our planet
so they act in a way a bit like a shield
for our planet right obviously we also
use them for things like detecting where
magnetic north is and all the rest but
they have this effect in space as well
one of the property now and again unless
it really gonna usually supposed to be
roughly every two hundred thousand year
that one point is around 200 thousand
years there would be a total ass or flip
from north and south you know so they
would flip over Norfolk now be yourself
afternoon north and the exact position
of the North and South Poles would also
shift a bit during this process right so
the last time this fully happened was
against seven hundred eighty thousand
years ago appeared we touched on but
definitely many with these reversals you
know going all the way back to the
beginning of our planet and when they
occur the fields will winkin
considerably first and this allows
cosmic radiation cosmic engines to come
into the system and now that there are
force that this itself may be harmful to
life we don't see they could be more
cancerous you know there's it could be
just severe impacts on plant life which
then of course has an impact on other
larger animals
that so these are brains are problematic
if it was to have time in our modern age
right which they think it may be
underway now there's signs that the
power - they're moving quite rapidly
they've been weakening considerably over
the last few decades but if there was a
let's say a really good fast reversal we
would have extensive problems because of
course it's going to impact all of our
high technology right all the electric
fields that we utilize but we're gonna
have a problem so this this could impact
of our satellites you know again if you
take out our satellites right most of
our high-tech world would so crumble
really right so it's something that is
monitored you know carefully there's a
concern we don't expect it to be so fast
as to be that you know next year
you know suddenly flips usually is over
centuries right I mean some of them have
taken thousands of years but we know the
shorter ones have been over you know a
few centuries but you know so these
essentially again mega events that
happen on a formerly understood cycle
got it and so how well accepted is the
idea that the geomagnetic reversals
occur and are important to pay attention
to yeah they're well-established because
what we can didn't find the reversed
fields in rocks
so when magma is produce a an event and
when it solidifies it will solidify with
the the field direction that was current
at that time so when geologists look at
ancient rocks you know they can
basically they can find you know their
different periods in time the magnetic
field in those rocks is opposite to the
direction that we have now and so over
time they've been able to pinpoint
fairly accurately when these past
reversals have occurred now the last one
lost completely one was seven hundred
eighty thousand years ago but there's
been one brings up the poles there's
been partial reversals where there's
been weakening and stuff but for
whatever reason we haven't had one since
then is it's it was understood that they
would be on roughly to every two hundred
thousand years
but something disrupted it at that point
right so it's never bounced back to the
the expected cycle for some reason got
it
that that makes sense okay so so let's
go to kind of the origins of human
history right or the Homo sapiens how
long ago are we talking about right when
you go to the earliest hominins now the
humans essentially part of the hominins
group okay but so all hominins are
humans so we tend to get humans as us
but that's a bit of misnomer essentially
the earliest hominins lived around about
67 million years ago now these would
have been just recognized them as being
a human relative but you're definitely
thinking more of a kind of Planet of the
Apes you know these were my men right so
the australopithecines for example if
you looked and they were they were
fairly short you know like four foot odd
you know and then they've got small
brains like shrimps eyes brains but they
have certain features to the skull and
to their anatomy that that tells us
they're on their way to being more like
us and less like you know chimpanzees
and orangutans so they have
distinguishing morphology and cranial
capacity that is increasing you know
they are on their way towards it but
then it means definitely you wouldn't
think of as being you know like you
forgot on the bus you know you would be
like that's the normal guy are cynics
you know these they're quite
recognisably more like Eggman it took
several million years for the forces of
evolution there's many different funds
actually involved and when we think of
natural selection of course you know
best known force that essentially if
you're suited to environment if you're
well to did you're more like to have
offspring if you're not you tend to die
off and that's the natural selection so
a mutation that there are random and
non-random changes in the genome which
sometimes give new abilities which are
beneficial or sometimes they're harmful
and
you need again to have a role in who
gets selected to be killed off do
survives but there are others we now
understand that there seems like we have
these feedback loops in epigenetics
where you know you can be changed by
your environment within a lifetime and
that can be passed on to at least a
couple of generations of your children
so if you go through a famine but your
system will change to adapt to that
famine you know the way you burn energy
but that can also be passed down so they
didn't say your grandchildren are no
longer living in famine but aspects of
their biology is still adapted to being
in a famine right so these disease
strange sort throw fast changes that can
occur we look at other things we have
them like translocation we have
movements of information in the junuh
genome which jumps about these
translocations which again these can
change and pour in our space an organism
so what starts with as evolution is far
more complex than simply selection right
as long as our Ganga and that jube to
these process we end up with a much
changed you know eight man if you like
by around two million years ago we have
the beginnings of Homo erectus now a
little day will be a recognizable human
relative that it's you know they were
start to get the height we could start
seeing a larger brain it's certainly not
smaller than ours
about half the size but we're getting
you know we're getting the features that
would be more in common to our own you
know species and they're in whether he
was talking it's interesting because
Homo erectus at the first of these
hominids to be really really took more
global more or less we have them all
throughout Eurasia there all the way
down to Southeast Asia there's been a
couple of skulls found in Americas which
appear to be Homo erectus but they
haven't been well studied so at the
moment that's you could say
controversial you can't say outright
that homo erectus were in America
because you know that the science hasn't
been done on those they're just
anomalies together my favorite things
and then we have some evidence that that
they moved through the islands of
Indonesia and Southeast Asia that we
have them out across many of the islands
Flores has tools on it the date of a
million years ago so erectus is really
the first global human right and then
this very pollution goes on from there
our own our own species Homo sapiens we
don't start to emerge until around about
a hundred thousand years ago roughly got
it
and you know the way that I look at this
and again this is coming from someone
who is not nearly as educated on the
topic as you are is there's really three
buckets of beliefs or story of the human
origin right
there is what I'll called the
evolutionary one which is we evolved out
of apes and and there's very kind of
scientific reasoning and explanation as
to how Homo sapiens eventually you know
you know kind of or the product of that
evolution then there is what I'll call
more of a fictitious or religious kind
of story
and this really is tied to the private
announcer run but the on a new guy but
this are you know these direct
descendants from the gods and goddesses
and they really had come down to
essentially decree the fate of humanity
right and this is depicted in a lot of
the Mesopotamian art and kind of again
very similar to what we would consider
like religion today and then there is
this hybrid that I think you are
probably much more into with some of
your research but before we get to your
specific research one of the debates
that I find fascinating one my favorite
books is Guns Germs and Steel by by
Jared Diamond I think that there's now
started to become a debate as to where
the early humans as we know them was
this more in the continent of Africa is
this more in the Asia and Australia
region of the world and how do you think
about that the geography of the origins
of humans and and kind of which camp do
you fall into I mean I have a book on
the topic I wrote a book called The
Forgotten Exodus the into Africa theory
of human evolution and the key being
their interior than out of because you
know I went through the literature
again through the academic studies you
know look to see who know who who is the
leaders in these fields and to find out
yeah what wouldn't happen and I had
reasons to do that was involved in some
research in Ecuador a mysterious
megalithic site there which simply
connected with a group of people called
the Lagoa Santa which are the I would
say is the earliest modern humans in the
Americas they were down in Brazil ago
Santa which seems to be 14 to 50,000
years ago
with a number of sites there rock
shelters what not getting didn't add up
with the conventional reason out of
Africa because you these turn out to be
kind of Aboriginal Australian morphology
like type people that so they shouldn't
really be there in the conventional
model where now if people sort familiar
the idea is that supposedly modern
humans came out of East Africa in a wave
around about 70,000 years ago and then
populated the Eurasia eventually
Australia and last of all America right
definitely isn't supposed to be like
Aboriginal Australians you know down in
America sort of fifty thousand years ago
so this is sort of a team time social
what I found is and I've spoke this up
with with all solid peer-reviewed papers
and well not you know I don't go out and
do archaeology but what I found is the
evidence really points to a Homo sapiens
population that is widespread normal to
him sometimes a very archaic very very
early homo sapiens who maybe would even
be given a different name we haven't
given them one yet but from around about
700 thousand years ago or so we have
these very archaic ancestors who are a
widespread they're not just in Africa
they are across Eurasia
they are down into Southeast Asia I
would say Australia though the evidence
has been removed by huge sea level
changes so we've lost a vast man around
down in Southeast Asia and Australia and
also there's no reason why they wouldn't
have reached the Americas okay so I
would say we have a vast population and
then what we can over time is climate
changes we have obviously
cataclysms lots of things will change
the locations where you'd find the bulk
of these people so they move both into
Africa out of Africa you know probably
wound to the Americas out of the
Americas
shifts in places or whether you know
there's a benefit to going somewhere
else you know there's more food
shirin's move we know that note speaks
by heartbeat as it were highly adaptable
we're highly mobile right
once we also find that this ancestral
population begins to diversify we start
to get in the end of the early nanda for
Denisovans but they were coming out of
this lineage the large-brained what I
would call the ancestors of Homo sapiens
and that these are in my view subspecies
which a number of scientists now
recognize that what we're going to all
those Homo sapiens neanderthalensis Homo
sapiens Denis over and homo sapiens
sapiens right because we've been ordered
to breed we know that we were in fact
most of us you know have some level of
Neanderthal or Denisovan or a mixture of
that and other hominid ancient problem
is in us right because essentially we're
one species you know we can we don't
have a problem with really there's
modern issues it does seem sometimes
that there may have been some problems
but essentially we know they were
successful and I've been to clearing
what happens is at one point there is a
cataclysm and this is at seventy three
thousand years ago I would choose the
Lake Toba supervolcano down in Indonesia
and the effects of this all right never
need nuclear winter time cataclysms but
it's fairly limited to the northern
hemisphere now this is a rather painting
life even if all across the northern
hemisphere is cooled in the temperature
and it's all during the night stage you
get acid rain your plants are dying
plants dying animals die fun most of
high in humans that depend on those
animals and those plants die the water
is poisoned all right without food
sulfuric acid so you can imagine because
a cataclysm on an immense scale like
what we have is a die-off of most of the
hominins of Eurasia now some of them are
pushed to the west and some are pushed
to the southeast
I mean if you get below the predator
you're okay so if you can get down into
iron in Southeast Asia into Australia
you're alright and if you can cross the
bab-el-mandeb straits and into Africa
from from the Middle East
women basically if you can get across
into Africa then again if you get to sub
Equatorial Africa you're safe now this
is actually what the evidence shows and
we have a problem in science right now
where there's a dogmatic approach that
reason Africa is is a holy cow that
cannot really be questioned every
article on the subject we'll start with
70 we know that 70,000 years ago men
gave us walked out of Africa the rest of
it we're still thinking about that but
that bit was beyond question now when
you do question it you find that the
evidence does not support it and in fact
is very clear we have refuges in
Australia and which is in tobacco to
Africa and after this climate event
dissipates about fifty five sixty
thousand years ago humans beginning to
repopulate Eurasia right but we were
there before it's a really populating
event got it and so as you think about
the evolution from that origin point
this is really where I think your
research you've come to the conclusion
and have a whole bunch of evidence that
that we'll talk about you kind of have
this like divergence from the
traditional thought of the evolution
maybe just start with kind of what the
conclusion is and then we'll get into
kind of what that's supporting evidence
that you have in a work that you've done
to to kind of back it up sure its most
basic i I go along with if you could say
the evidence for usually processes as
you can see as I've sort of said there
you know I I'm not disputing that we
have various pressures and there's
various factors of how the DNA code
itself functions that the causing
pollution in species right so I'm not
contesting that per se so the difference
in my work is I say that up until around
seven hundred and eighty thousand years
ago that asbestos we can say you know
it's largely understood evolutionary
forces at work now there doesn't mean
that there's nothing else going on - and
the evidence is not strong enough to
flat-out say anything else happens I do
want to clarify one thing though you're
not familiar with
panspermia that you know I am a
panspermia theorist if you like that I
accept the evidence that DNA itself
arrives on this planet from space that
it doesn't emerge out of a rock pool
here that life isn't just coming out of
that that's that's not my position that
I agree with a number of very well
respected academics who have theorized
this and it's not saying I've come up
with the argument that DNA is a true
code that you can even think of it as a
as a terraforming technology right that
you spray and you spray your pills are
full of materiality material on the
planet you come back you know in a few
millions you're gonna have a life okay
because that's what it does it adapts to
its adapts to its environment changes
out environment produces the gas in is a
new surface for the planet that's been
our position like I've going with that
so I've been doing anything contained a
true code and that it's extremely
intelligent essentially need to think of
this as really as an AI writer than like
hospital intelligence being created by
someone out there and it's been sprayed
down here then to some degree I would
say to true AI right but so you have
this code in there which we don't fully
understand what it's doing but it seems
to adapt to things it's very intelligent
it guides our adaption it guides our
evolution so that's important
consideration however I don't know seven
or eight thousand years ago we see a
clustering of a normally this right and
now I never nominees
that's my thing as we said in India so
when I see those I think aha you know
what the heck is going on here why is it
that science is stumbling over something
and they say look we know that in the
fossil record that around roughly a.m.
2,000 years ago we get a certain
acceleration in skull size in the
cranial capacity of early humans it just
absolutely
Rockets upwards okay beyond any
relationship with bloody master index it
just suddenly starts rocketing up that
was one understood but what we didn't
have before of course was genetic
technologies where we could investigate
what was going on at that time right
then that of course has changed we've
been able to go into the genome and
explore and what turns out is
there are a range of strange anomalies
at that point and I consider them to be
fingerprints of engineering by an
advanced intelligence so that's fun Dena
Malisse writes it so pretty much just to
summarize kind of where you come out on
this is there is pretty well accepted
and well verified science that there was
a change in skull size and there's kind
of this inflection point at one point in
history what now is starting to come out
is it wasn't just the skull size change
but there was also change in the genetic
code of Homo sapiens that change I think
you are in the camp of saying that is
less evolutionary and it was likely that
there was some external force that acted
upon that change or created that change
that after it yeah and one important
things to say here is that there's a
number of leading academics again I
don't say there's just Mooney coming up
with this on my own
right because your leading academics for
his are called professor Paul Davies who
is considered to be the man that
humanity will turn to you know if we
identify the presence of an external
intelligence right so you know he's a
leading astrophysicist he's an
astrobiologist and mathematician you
know an all-round great finger and he
proposes the idea that you know
alongside SETI research of all the radio
waves or looking at exoplanets that we
could look at the genome and see whether
or not there's been a modification in
prehistory which may be carried out by a
visiting intelligence and that this
could be a signature message in a bottle
left for when agents you know arises on
this planet so and this is supported by
quite a number of them very intelligent
people in the world of science right so
this is not some strange idea and in
fact I managed to get a question across
to Seth Shostak at the SETI Institute
right and asking whether he thought
business was valid research and
he lives on a recent podcast he was
talking to a guy whose notes got mine up
anyway he actually clarifies it yes you
know he green his disease legitimate
research and it probably should be done
but you know things just probably a
waste of time that we won't find
anything I mentioned so they would only
take a couple of weeks to do this
bear in mind how long it took to not
find radio waves so far right decades
and they'll probably go on indefinitely
without finding radio waves with
millions of dollars going into that and
yet these guys are telling us we can do
a simple search of the genetic data that
we already have it might take a couple
weeks and we can potentially find a
confirmation of patience for visitation
no don't it's like you straight aways
that's something we're doing well here's
the thought process is again it goes
back to and why I want to start the
conversation off with I'm of the belief
that science should encourage
experimentation and that there should be
no sacred cows right and the ability to
expand our minds into various
possibilities and then go put them
through scientific rigor is really
important right it's kind of belief that
you know a lot of innovation happens
from people who are not from an industry
right it's because it takes to think
outside the box they get break through
us and so when I think about kind of you
know the work that you're doing I want
to really kind of push deep on you know
this inflection point in the genetic
code what are the anomalies that that
you've identified or others have
identified that that lend itself to say
look there just is an inflection point
there is a change in the genetic code at
some point in history
how long ago are we talking about and
what are those enough sure I mean the
key ones relate to again dying a preface
it's a bit for people aren't familiar
when it's asked you know if an
extraterrestrial is it was wanting to
modify us in a way that could be
detected or almost amorphous and you
know as a happenstance it could be
detected the challenges would have to be
in areas that are highly conserved and
really in the non-coding DNA now the
reason for this is highly conserved
means essentially very rarely changing
that these are very
ordinary the code let's take the area
that means you have a long life if you
don't be loans you're not going to be
well so highly conserved code stays very
stable so that's what I say look if
there was a signature we would expect it
to be found in those regions now that's
really important because that's where we
find a whole load of these anomalies is
in is actually only highly the most
highly conserved regions of non-coding
DNA right and this is a mask which what
we find is four star to be a couple this
was called hrs and the men themselves
physically the human accelerated regions
might strips of code the seams have
undergone anomalous acceleration of
changes in the in the short times the
you know well there shouldn't be any
change I think more specific example we
have Sokol har one the first one of
these was detected now they contrasted a
118 DNA letter long piece of code across
chickens chimpanzees and humans now
between chickens in the chimpanzees
there was a two letter difference so
they realize that every hundred and
fifty million years you get one
successful mutation during this area
okay so unbelievably stable you know
very important if you family changes
usually the organism dies but so then
they're in for will contrast that chimps
against humans who roughly five or six
million years or so of divergence right
they expected there to be no difference
because by these odds or 150 million
years per letter but what they found
instead was eighteen letters had changed
right so their minds were immediately
blown because you know there was just no
explanation for that level of change and
so when they ran the the computation
system as a software design into
computers they came up with it being a
zero percent chance of this having
occurred by any understood eeveelution
mechanisms right so in other words
they've got nothing right and then
they're not offering any explanation for
this they've now found several hundred
of these and the
when they understand seem to be to do
with fetal development particularly
things of development relating to the
human brain which is again this
anomalous and narrow that primate has a
brain so to anything like ours and in
fact most of the differences between us
and other primates are in genes to do
with the brain right and on top of that
we find a load of other anomalies some
of these at our engine temperature ours
are not really genes okay they're in
what's called areas for control genetic
expression right so they will change the
function of a gene or turn it on or off
but we also have genes that are
anomalous there's a there's a strip of
code from one gene which has been
described as having as though it was
snipped down to the longer gene copied
and then put back in that sounds really
like Chris bar-type technologies right
and then the second of these where they
say they're not a brain gene which they
say the appeal is fully formed suddenly
out of non-coding DNA there's no
something was just created the gene from
the important areas I think that's for
the neocortex folds in the brains and
that you've got dis gingersnap
containers right non-coding material and
there's incredible function for our
brain and so you've got those and then
you've got the fusion of chromosome 2
which occurs to get 700 80 thousand
years ago this time when these rapid
brain changes going on as we've
mentioned and this one fuse is on an
active Cheney which is to do with the
brain the reproductive system and the
immune system ok key areas that you
might want to get that if you're working
on the genome and that coincides with
some what was a super huge benefits
because we know that there's a total
replacement those underway with all the
hominids on earth right before it all
about 48 is for every understand it all
primates had 48 chromosomes right humans
today you have 46 unless you have a
genetic illness in a condition that's
risen from infusion or replication and
this is this is a total replacement so
we wouldn't expect this with respect to
have a say a small ritalin natural
mutation right which we probably used
neutral
or usually negative then you would
expect there to be a small subgroup of
people that have 46 chromosomes and a
greater group just in a 48 right that's
logic so it's a good way to explain this
it and think is you have to have a small
group of people to all develop this in
short succession so they become a
breeding popular and insular in isolated
breeding population and it has to give
them incredible benefits for it to
persist and not to go back into the
background and for it to become so
widespread right that everyone on earth
ends up with this suggest that the
changes was so incredibly beneficial
that nobody else could compete with
those that had this change for right so
that is another one is very anomalous
for like how did that happen
today he denied looking at and say well
hey with CRISPR gene drives which is a
cutting-edge technology that's just
coming in now you can actually modify
write the current in such a way that
when to two individuals interbreed so
you may know FEMA usually you know copy
of information from each unique gene
drives you can make it so that your new
modified with making older writes that
have the other parent yeah so no matter
who they're the human which is with you
know if there's another common in Homo
erectus for example right which the
child will be like the modified parent
not a mixture of the two and that also
is another way you can eradicate species
they're using from mosquitoes right so
you can use that to ensure that everyone
that's born from those unions will be
the new kind of creature right so that's
okay it's fascinating to see that that's
something to do now and that would
easily explain this total replacement is
that a use of economic risk bar plus
gene drives technology right so we have
these enrollment is glaring anomalies
there that are clustering in almost
period seven or eight thousand years ago
when the brain suddenly goes into
overdrive and we have a reason one
believes it is just and as I said
they're in the regions where the leading
experts tell us that we should look if
we were to look if we were to find
extraterrestrial
those are the areas we can look to and
likely the academics are telling us we
should look and see if it's there so all
of that's happening and yet somehow
that's being left to me you know instead
of a new academic which is the strangest
part of it all really Scott's girl want
to know who has the best URL crypto calm
that's right
crypto calm there crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto calm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine calm tell
them pomp Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
ether at block five and receive 6%
annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm slash pop again
block 5 comm slash pop to sign up and
start earning interest on your crypto
today and I guess the big thing here is
that there's two buckets to this right
the first bucket is identifying the
anomalies which it seems like there is
enough people who recognize and identify
them right so it order argue that the
anomalies don't exist the second bucket
is how did they get there right or what
will the force that or kind of the
reason and now this is where I think you
get much less consensus much less
confidence and because of that
uncertainty in answer you end up getting
a wide variety everything from natural
evolution to something that looks like
CRISPR to something that literally could
have been sprayed on people that I mean
there's all kinds of wild theories there
I guess my question to you is you have a
very specific kind of idea around what
happened what is the evidence that
you've either located or the work that
you've done to specifically identify
that specific theory as to what drove
these anomalies sure the Germans moving
on that date it's about 780 thousand
which I don't you find in any other
models to be honest nobody else seems to
give you a specific point which is
important you know but the reason I can
do that is not only to be now these
anomalous but I was already looking at
that period because I was worth
following some clues in a set of
mythology mythology but information
that's come out of Aboriginal Australian
stories mythology from which emerge idli
and again this is allegedly that they
have an artifact or artifacts that they
call true Inga right which is this a
small supposedly stone-like object with
some symbols on it which they can seem
to be the most sacred objects right and
that this can't in some way transfer the
information and that they get historical
information from this object now it's in
the stories that they share there may
follow genes whatever you want to call
it there is evidence that there was a
visitation they claimed there was beings
that came from the Pleiades it's one of
the areas specifically mentioned
that description what sound like
wormholes know some kind of great tree
trunk that connects us to this place or
a tunnel or a rope right there's also
anything in there that we're fascinating
to me and on top of that there's
descriptions of a craft that comes here
right there particularly a crystalline
craft now be the static okay no it's
just stories laddie as you said there's
lots of mythologies in Annunaki knew the
Bible so what's different here life or
there was there was a nothing there that
was specific that I thought well I can
test this there's a description of this
very large crystalline craft it's a
basis of the living craft right for me
I'm thinking Sofia AI because on the
cutting edge of the nail Iowa we know
that the fields are telling us they
think in the future they will be vast
silicon networks inhabited by self-aware
AI or even upload in human consciousness
into these silicon networks right that
we know that's essentially where the
arrow is pointing now being up-to-date
with some of that and understanding that
well I'm sure about the eluvian
crystalline object I'm straightening
iron over this you know it might sound
to some people like woo woo you know
that big crystals but if you understand
that if you realize oh hang on we know
this is the kind of thing we should
expect to see from an advanced
extraterrestrial civilization right so
then those specific descriptions of this
feed being in orbit breaking up material
raining down and enough they're they're
everything well if this is real I can
check it in the geological papers and
see if there's anything that matches
this now my part of me you're thinking
of no way that that's going to be like
it's real
there's so Len would go right 785 years
ago that you know I'm not confident he
would still exist so I went through and
it turns out that there's a 100 getting
along with stewing in science about a
material called
australoid tektite now after a tektite
is and essentially it's a 75 percent
silica mixture with other alimony and a
wide range of the chemical magnesium so
I think there's about a dozen or more
chemicals in there Vania it's it's
particularly anomalous even if you look
at math when I was taking you across and
this distribution feel to it it's
enormous like the material covers
between 10 to 30% of the Earth's surface
yeah which we're normal saying and
impact right we can impact even a fairly
large one the material usually means in
a fairly you know fairly tight cluster
yeah we can definitely point to have it
that wide span if I didn't know that
there's nothing comparable right that
this maturity edge but the other thing
about it comes in a unique form which is
called a button tektite now some of the
material in other words came from space
to form this particular shape it looks
like a nose cone of a rocket you know so
NASA they looked at this because they
understood that this had to been shaped
by the aerodynamic forces of material
passing through the atmosphere from
space
okay they also worked out that the
source body was an object at least a
kilometer in diameter that was in orbit
around our planet when it broke up and
that the material carried on and a
horizontal planes in the earth
essentially you need to come in orbit
and came through a shallow angle had
secondary melting which formed these
button shapes right but they literally
was in a sphere and spheres spheres of
liquid form in space so it was liquid in
space in the vacuum in fact there's
bubbles of hard vacuum in the material
so we know they have formed in space and
then it melted on its way through and we
have this material across from the seven
tip of Australia in fact Antarctica all
the way up to southern China and Laos
you have this enormous distribution
field so seeing that and understanding
that hang on a minute this is the exact
signature for the kind of event that's
being described and then finally the
date on it is 780 thousand years ago
right which is bang on than this these
challenges are happening right in the
brain and the genome that we've got this
what matches to this object and they're
told mother's come through a wormhole
and you know a moving ship right
something hang on a second this is this
is crazy because there's not an actual
solution this because asteroids comets
and second the only thing they're made
of I believe we've done pretty extensive
work on that
do not mesh with the chemical
composition of this material that's the
first thing for example asteroids you
can have silica up to around 60% you
don't ever get it up to 75% silica also
comets and asteroids of the size that
we're talking about here cannot be
pulled into orbit by the Earth's gravity
in fact they'd be accelerated past us
right as they they came that close they
would essentially be accelerated past
all they'd crashing into us yeah they
don't end up in orbit so what kind of
contractor can slow down park itself in
orbit well this is a problem now so
don't talk about that they took my what
material mainly of how you rain down
nobody seems to tackle epistolary and
normally that this thing is parked in
orbit yeah
so that's an absolutely mesh with what
these legends claim now we have that and
then there is the second part which we
touched on earlier which is the amongst
information is a claim of a
multi-directional bombardment of
asteroids around the same time five
years later in fact it's quite specific
that there is this other bombardment and
like I'm thinking there's no way you
know that this has happened because I've
never heard of it you know I think I'm
fairly well versed in ancient events
particularly big catechisms a passion of
mine I like Catholicism to the history
so I went searching for that to see if
there was any evidence of that part of
this this claim and it turns out that in
2015 a team of geologists from
university in Germany very found this
multi-generational bombardment that we
discussed earlier right so it's a very
recent discovery so nobody should have
known about it you know in ancient times
in Australia more than average looks
like it's a 2015 discovery and that
these things were but not something that
we normally when we talked about in
Antarctica right leaving a crater 200
miles by 200 miles you know absolutely
enormous that this is also part of the
claim that this event happens around the
same time now I didn't know is about is
that supposedly these impacts may have
actually caused the magnetic reversal
and this has been looked at at the
moment that they think these huge
impacts are one initiated to sudden
field reversal and
why we haven't seen one since this
destabilized the normal cycle of the
Earth's field and so we're getting a
cluster of Megara vents right right on
that moment which also happen to fit
with this narrative because coming out
of an Aboriginal string in you know
cultural setting and they relate to an
object which can community information
now moves that object I would posit that
it's a brace well probe and so one of
the reasons why I wanted to have this
conversation was you you had said to me
that there are essentially this
identification or detection right and of
an alien techno signature in the form of
an extraterrestrial post biological
artificial intelligence craft that's
essentially what you're describing right
now right is that the that you have kind
of created here and are in the process
of testing is that what we see in those
early stories or are etc end up
coinciding with scientific revelations
or studies around that the breaking up
of some material that ends up striking
the earth etc or claim is it's unlikely
to be more of a meteor shower as much as
it is a certain type of material that we
previously had not seen on earth before
right so so it's something that came not
from Earth but how do you make the
connection from that material to you
know kind of the extra-terrestrial post
biological artificial intelligence craft
like what does that mean and and how do
you make that connection from the
material to that that theory sure I mean
because we would expect it to be a
highly silica material and say this is
way beyond the percentage of silica
that's known in asteroids meteorites or
comets so irrespective you have the
compound there's other chemicals in
there that make it
unlike other unlike asteroids or comets
okay
but they're really the signature for me
is this extraordinarily high level of
silica because if we have lucky the
quartz crystal being the main component
of a dipping a I craft then we would
expect melted silica to be you know the
highest percentage of the debris from
the destruction of a craft like that and
that's what we find in it so it's a
actually parallels what we should expect
if we were to be visited by a car for
them if we firstly that it's destroyed
in orbit or whatever
exact reasons but if you hadn't been we
don't know no evidence obviously but the
second thing is again is that the fact
that this can park itself yeah now I've
looked at the astronomy and physics
information on this and he's English
stating that these objects cannot end up
in orbit I talk very that's people that
they won't see if they will posit a
natural solution for this then you have
to explain the physics right you have to
say how can this vast object park itself
in orbit yeah and then you have to deal
with the fact that they also that
several papers pointing to an extrasolar
origin for this material due to
detection of the effects of cosmic
radiation on it and also some of the
isotopic values in it the suggestion has
come from outside of our solar system
which again is important so we have an
object from beyond our solar system that
means using high in silica and that can
stop and move into an orbit right and
that happens to coincide with several
other huge anomalous events right
including this fuse later this
bombardment which almost resets the
earth and then strange changes in the
genome of early hominins right and we
have this connecting to and a little
story of an object which sounds like a
very small probe which if people are
familiar with Bracewell probes
essentially it's a again I'd rather sell
for AI but on a smaller scale an object
that can be left on a planet there's
sort of called a sentinel probe that
they can record they can maybe do other
other functions but they can record and
they can also interact at some point now
the theory bribe by the scientist
Bracewell
was that these could be who used to make
contact with the civilization if you
send them out into space
you leave very the hard a I on board
they have certain human self repair
functions and so maybe the cell
replication functions so you have these
things spreading out across the cosmos
arriving on planets or even hiding in
orbit and orbiting around planets
watching them or being left and that you
just leave them as a technical is
indistinguishable from background
material so let's say you hide it looks
like a rock yeah it's all experience it
truly advanced technology will probably
unrecognizable to us so that's again
that's understood in in these levels of
theoretical Sciences on these subjects
that you know that we wouldn't
necessarily know what attack looks like
so if you imagine a group of ancient
aboriginal people encounter a graceful
probe not knowing what it is and that
this thing is able to communicate
information
I would suggest through a voice to skull
type technology which we have now in MIT
in places they're working on these and
then can transfer information starts
telling them about its how it's going at
the background the story I know they
sell it Terry I think that the sacred
artifact at home the artifact it's put
into the most you know the Holy of
Holies you know it's supposed to look on
these things right you're not only their
highest initiated people and then if you
can go near the thing well that's the
culture understanding particularly the
art obviously renting people and another
another group that also have this
disbelief and that this object seems to
then be producing valid information
which can be verified that's the kingdom
you know I haven't seen it I haven't got
a touch Terry so you could say okay
maybe it's not now I don't know but the
fact is the information that I've looked
down and I've used led me to the needs
astonishing discoveries that I never
knew existed
I've been looking for this if it wasn't
for that and it turns out you have at
seven hundred eighty thousand years ago
one of these events this strange object
in orbit the changes in the genome the
bombardment and the magnetic reversal
around seven hundred eighty thousand
years ago in some but externally that we
don't have that as a well-known
discussion you know the dinosaur subject
the fact is there was more
events going on and they're not
well-known he's really bizarre like I
said he was a foolish thing these
subjects I hadn't heard of any of these
until I started doing this research is
really strawberry yeah and I think you
know as I look at this right you spent
many many more hours than me on this but
but the way that I break down kind of
work you've done so far is you have
taken a pretty well-established accepted
scientific fact around some materials
some of the bombardments etc and then
you have also used what I'll consider
more theoretical constructs right so
whether it's somebody else's right in
terms of the the methodology that other
people expected or things that you have
and where you've come to a conclusion is
those things when overlaid on each other
all intersect with at the same time
period as a number of very interesting
anomalies that can again be identified
and are fairly well accepted from a
scientific standpoint I guess the the
big question that I have for you right
is because when you combine
well-accepted fact that has been
established through scientific rigor
with things that are more theoretical
you introduce the idea of like a
confidence level right because the
theater people component of this ends up
being harder to to back up with with
supporting evidence because you still
pretty able do the scientific rigor what
would you put the confidence level you
have in terms of kind of this theory
beaming spirit and in the future being
able to to prove some of it to a greater
extent than we are today but I'm happy
for people to look at the mythology part
of it if you want as being simply
something that got me interested in the
topic now whether it's real whether
there's really this artifact and it can
do all this you know I can't say because
again you know to be objective I didn't
see the object you know I didn't have an
experience with it right so I don't you
could say
okay well if you discount that you're
still left with the genuine you know
just a rigorously scientifically tested
and one leads which are clustering
together which is a normal anomaly right
because when you get those kind of
things happening at the same point in
time again that's a red flag for
something strange is going on and then
on top of that you can scientifically
evaluate things like how would you you
know why is this object made of
materials that to get on typical right
for other bodies in our solar system
what causes it to stop an orbit these
are testable right same as with the
genetic data again that's testable
because you can if you infer that
there's been possible modification now
what would be required is geneticists to
spend some time focusing particularly on
changes that happened around seven
hundred eighty thousand years ago and
all those anomalies the HAR s and also
on the fusion event right these are
testable and on top of that may be
testable if you really think about it I
mean family are those in the genetics
field on finding the fingerprints of
master geneticists right and just as
we're going into the genetic revolution
with Chris Bar if we can find the
fingerprints of master geneticists who
could who could make humans out of these
very early hominins but there's gotta be
invaluable information you know if I was
in the genetics field I would want to
hone in and see what you don't do
because we're about to open Pandora's
Box right we will know that yeah well
then we're gonna start modifying babies
instead we're going to start creating
new humans wouldn't it be nice to have a
starter in that from an extra
intelligence that knew what their hair
cake was stealing and was able to go in
there and almost play us like a piano at
the code level right but this means coat
these master code breakers you know the
one in changed he was if that it's valid
yeah if the evidence is really pointing
to that but my mind that is zero percent
chance of things changes by known even
usually means zero so far no other
solutions except for an intelligence
being involved yeah if we can go ahead
and find what they did and understand it
maybe we can evade the horrors of
experimenting on humans
with all these technologies and know
what their hell we're doing right and
actually fix problems instead of create
problems so I think there's a financial
and ethical reasons for why you might
want to check this you know really
important reasons and that we have valid
science that wouldn't have these har is
identified we have their knowledge on
chromosome tutors you know it's there
all right
I'm not arrested I cannot go to any
length I would like right to validate
this wire like is the engagement of
people who are capable of now going in
there and saying hey yeah actually you
know what this doesn't look like the
signature
you know what we would do if we had to
know how this is how we would change a
human right because that's something
that there's people capable of doing and
again with this object astronomers
physicists should be able to look again
at the hosta like materials say hey
could this being the current position of
an advanced class because surely our
space scientists right and are you know
a designer sister wouldn't you want to
know what I know a treasure most girls
that ship out of right so again these
know huge drivers they've people take
this seriously and look at it you know
the potential benefits are enormous
versus the costs I mean we already have
most the data there so the costs are
minimal the payout could be enormous
beyond imagining so what is your
thoughts on CRISPR technology kind of as
we go forward is this something that
you're you're in support of and you
think should be encouraged and
experimented with or are you more on the
side of hey this is very dangerous and
we should be credibly cautious and
probably shouldn't push the pace of
innovation where there's no drives
dangerous it's also inevitable
do any controls will ever stop it
completely and we've already seen that
you know I started to China today
changes to babies you know permission
you just did it right I mean I think
there's been recently some tests and
emerging swims and human DNA is there so
that stuff's going to happen whether I
agree there or not but I actually would
support in a way I think if we want to
be a cosmic civilization if we want to
go into space right we are going to have
to use these technologies I don't
believe it's possible for a homo sapiens
to go out in Coraline space we suffer
with in calculated conditions you just
go happen to be in the space station you
support to basically degrade away yeah
and then we'll have links with the no
Lewis field but the Earth's were doubles
which means that if you were to relocate
to Mars it's not clear that we can even
mean produce there there are fertility
in studies is maybe we won't actually be
able to have children on another planet
now to colonize worlds like if your
bones dig your own lead you start
getting weird illnesses you can't have
children you know at some point we have
to look say look if you want to go into
space it's not just about the technology
take with you it has to be the organism
itself has to be changed and has to be
adapted for the environment is going
into so I would support that as long as
people are happy to talk therapies
threatened for them to be an astronaut
now I don't know whether I'd say it's
right to experiment on the frutas and
say more than a movie engineer the next
generation of space people but we're
asking them we're just going to change
the theatres is June you know that that
I wouldn't agree with everything that's
very very much an effortful issue but if
there are genetic therapies which an
adult can say well okay I'm willing to
to have that done you know I want to go
into space then and yeah I think that is
the only way that we are going to
explore space well what is the issue
with kind of the human as an organism in
space is it like a radiation thing or
what exactly is causing that the
degradation of the human organism when
gravity one of the major we're likely to
end up in a environment with our exact
you know the next strength of gravity
that we have here that's that's a major
issue for us
you know we are what I chose to are the
bleeding will I mean they say that you
find a planet that has a different
balance of gases right but there's more
completely poisonous but but there you
would struggle to breathe and the
gravity was maybe 50 percent right and
then it's it's time to move around the
star is different you know in the day is
a different length but we have not
promised that all of our natural rhythm
to be thrown out our breathing can be a
problem
so say making reproductions a problem we
can have all of these issues right
bones your bone basic clear you start to
lose bone density so you have all these
problems if you can modify humans for
that environment then you can maybe
overcome that we can change you can
change a fundamental level our
requirements for breathing in over our
reproductive system there's all sorts
things that we can put on chiliedu if we
have a for our understanding of the DNA
code and how the essential parts of the
genome particularly these highly
conserved images because if you start
playing with highly conserved regions
now if we bear in mind that through
natural mechanisms you know it takes 150
million is for one successful mutation
like in some of these areas obviously
they're they're very dangerous areas to
just play with if you don't know what
you're doing you're really gonna kill
almost every experimental visa so so but
if we can understand those areas you can
you can really change your most anything
about us you don't need that much about
hybrid he wasn't with my my work I don't
listen when you splice enough romanian
material you can hybridize with other
species so you can put in some genes
from a fungus some genes from a cow or a
yes some degree of that but I don't
think mainly what we're gonna be looking
at is modifying the code at a very
fundamental level and not necessarily
having to hybridize too much although
that will be part of the story yes we're
going to take things that we think of
beneficial you know you want to take a
gene from a squid because it gives you a
benefit to live on Mars right that for
some reason it gives you a benefit so
yeah we'll put that in but a lot of this
I think is yet modifying the code
broadly support it as long as it's again
done in an ethical setting but I mean
the ethics are complex because you're
not just changing or so if you have
children of course you've just solute
for your children that they were being
Homo sapiens 2.0 right that they don't
get a say that even though you're not
modifying the features if you want to
find the parents and they have offspring
the offspring have had that modification
like you or not right so obviously the
ethics of these processes and orderly
complex but their nature changes us
without asking so yeah part of this I
think is
there's two components in my mind one is
just the end state right eventually we
will be genetically modified you know
kind of these weird combinations of
science technology and humans right and
there's some very easy uncontroversial
things like hey if we could present
prevent disease or we could present
prevent some sort of genetic issues that
would probably be a positive thing right
freshly we could do with no side effects
but there are kind of much larger
arguments around just hey humans want to
run faster jump higher be smarter you
know kind of doubt the augmentation I
think the controversy is really how do
we get to that end game right and so
look at China verse three u.s. you know
I'm probably of the mindset that China
has a significant advantage when it
comes to biotechnology you know that the
biohacking the CRISPR technology tester
because frankly they're just willing to
do things that here in the United States
where either one unwilling to do or to
we we think is unethical and they have
no problem with it right it's a cultural
different yeah and so you know again it
goes back to the idea that the group
that has the ability to provide
resources for something to have there's
large people working on it and to
encourage experimentation they're just
likely it's the probability that they're
going to make faster progress because
they're spending more time on it yeah
absolutely and I think that we probably
will see China and somebody leading this
and I feel like okay I don't addition to
the way different cultures fit but we
know that the Chinese culture
historically is about kind of what's
good to try and you know he's thinking
within China's boundaries but using
resources and relationships to increase
that and objects heck sometimes
borrowing ideas and one of where's the
US Europe but so we tend have this
there's talks about this global idea
that you know making a global community
and and the way we think is very
different I think China's more
insulation is in that respect they're
not rich although people say they're
looking oh they'll invade if you look at
China I think my concern about is your
what's good for China and China keeping
you know its own its own culture in its
own way is distinct right whereas we
like this idea for low blades open and
complete different I thought that within
the truth - that is very different and
that yeah they are they are willing to
push in this package and we know that
historically even that they were ahead
of us in science if you're back
you know centuries ago making this
gunpowder and stuff you know they they
had starting revolutions that were
unparalleled right in the world beyond
at the time to their care drive again
like the Arab world at one point again
was well had you know it's in the
sciences with medicines so think
historically yeah I think that the
culture favors that kind of progressive
thinking in some ways in other ways not
I mean there's ways that you know we
wouldn't probably say well that's really
progressive internet but in the tech I
mean in this you know in the biohacking
astir I think that you are they're gonna
really leap ahead and clearly I get in
new areas where obviously was seeing
that in a blockchain tech Android rule
yeah I see them and with some of these
yeah these kind of super people probably
ahead of us and I think a lot of these
millionaires I'm looking to answer that
the idea that you know that having your
children for many different ways well
the idea you know that we know
historically that you know the Sun the
dragon guide all the other thinking
about making the best children and the
one-child policy which led to you know
that what we have a boy because the boy
is bath whereas purposes you know so
that kind of thing as well which we
wouldn't be so familiar with in the West
right which means idea that you know
there's also this iPhone only that
focuses and now they wanted to make that
perfect child you know that it's going
to be the best strongest that the fear
it's getting fits with the cultural
background so this I told me surprised
if we get left behind in the mean as I
say they already got might experiment
with the chimp and the genes and it's
that was in China because the the guys
actually a u.s. scientist I mean he he
couldn't do it in the US because of the
regulations so he just moved experiment
to China and we'll see where the other
experiment where Chris barbers used to
modify a couple of babies there so it's
already happening
right so it's sort of inevitable then
lasted a change in the mine state in the
US and in Europe that we will be left
behind by the Chinese and they will have
genetically enhanced people you know so
it's what we do with that I mean I guess
we'd have to in some way I don't know
once you're on that do we go with it or
do we just
conservative look I tend to think that
say uh there's a middle ground right so
doesn't have to be binary and what it is
is you basically create opt-in programs
right there's a lot of people who more
than willing to opt in in exchange for
whether it's payment whether it is the
potential to solve a problem they have
right whether it is they have a disease
or something like that and they're
willing to do more experimental
treatments or even there's plenty of
people who literally would be willing to
take the risk because they would like to
run faster jump higher or be smarter
right and kind of the Augmented stuff
but but I'm more of the belief that
every human individual should have free
choice and should be allowed to kind of
take the risks that they want as long as
they're educated on it right so I don't
think that it's a thing and just blindly
you know one day wake up and say hey I
want to you know get crisper done but
but I do think that if there was some
sort of educational course or something
that somebody went through and they were
very you know I'm kind of blatantly and
simply told what the potential upsides
are and what the potential risks were
and then you make a decision for
themselves right and kind of the
government's to stay out of their lives
frankly if we're okay with the idea of
sending people one way to Mars right
which is something that there's been a
lot volunteers have said that they would
go on a one-way trip to Mars yeah but
that's what Mars one more this right and
obviously SpaceX another people are
going to try it yeah but we know as if
there's a huge chance that that first
mission is a disaster but we would allow
people to go into that disaster right
because it's in the name progression and
they want to do as you say they're
choosing to go now if we're happy to
send people what is probably they do you
know a disaster us doing the mission to
Mars the first manned mission may be
successful but I think most of us would
be conservative in their thinking it the
first time probably not yet but what we
could say to those people well hey look
I'm looking you're willing to throw your
lives of this you know we can also offer
you chingling therapies that will give
you a better chance at least of
surviving on Mars you know isn't that
I think that's the right thing to do
because if they're gonna be probably
stuck there and you know that they're
gonna struggle with the gravity in the
the atmosphere nor is it any more
radical to offer them these changes they
need to send them to me from an alien
planet like without any real way of
surviving they're happy on being a
bubble which could fail anytime I think
that you know again you start if you're
willing to throw people into what looks
like disasters why not let them have a
choices to do other you know other
things paralleled to that which I think
that yeah these China technology a power
no more risky or crazy than send people
one way to Mars absolutely and look we
could talk about this stuff forever one
of the things I want to make sure we
talk about before we go is you know a
lot of what we're talking about here
it's not lost on me and probably not
lost on you that either one it's
unpopular too there's some people who
just kind of write it all off and say
that's just crazy talk and then three is
there's actually a lot of establishment
or incumbent organization scientist etc
that that will go to great lengths to
prevent the spread of the information
because it potentially threatens their
position of power importance or kind of
work you've actually had a number of
occasions certainly levels of censorship
that you dealt with I think recently
there was a situation where you were
cited in an article and then all of a
sudden you know it was kind of deleted
and it was you know really that
publication saying hey he's not a
professional anthropologist right you
know you can't use work maybe just talk
a little bit about your experiences with
trying to share these ideas and and what
you've run into both positive you know
from the supporting side and then also
negative from the obstacle side sure I'm
gonna have so obviously I don't have
some quiet supporters I do talk to some
scientists who are helpful they give me
feedback on things they do but hopefully
in quiet because again it's detrimental
to them to be publicly associated with
me right because because I'm dealing
with radical ideas or ideas that aren't
in the consensus so anything that I sad
but I understand that I understand why
they don't want to be publicly
associated with me in my work right
which again but that's a cultural
problem and then
have you out of course the media which
is a big issue because without doing
this kind of information out into the
median if a dissemination then there's
no pressure for scientists to look at it
because then they grow you know mostly
aware of it for start you know obviously
the world of framework works usually
discoveries are supposed to come from a
university or a Foundation press release
goes to the media then they publish an
art score you know make it popular in
which case it brings more support to
that research etc if you're on the
outside of that knee contacting
journalists usual results in one of two
things are there total silence foliage
into the spam box you know whatever or a
reply of you know not really interested
kindly because it's not worth expecting
right they're thinking in those some Sun
crime forever you know that they don't
get as far as to even know if you have
real evidence right we'll never get to
that cuz you're not PhD so-and-so from
University searched and searched by the
tour closes but the exception we had
there was I had a scientist who was also
science journalist who saw the validity
in my work now that I mean he agreed
with all of the you know the hypothesis
but he saw the validity and he saw I was
using you know people viewed academic
services right which is the gold
standard sources I'm not going on
pretending I'm doing archaeology or
genetics like on well well it's none of
that when you show pseudoscience and not
so designs because you'll be similar
size then the sources that you use a
pseudoscience is because you took discs
most of the leaders in their fields
right and so it's got a hero an article
for Forbes and that went out was dissent
last December and within a couple of
hours it been spiked by senior editors
and deleted and he was told never to
refer to me as a source again because
yeah I wasn't a suitable academic source
for the story and so and I think you
said leaders making sense because I
received there is a criticism of the
work that's the place to have it is he
put it in public scientists can see it
very can clarify in the comments or
whether respondents article right saying
things and is wrong because of the
occasion this and to have that
discussion which he said is a legitimate
process right you have their discussions
silencing that conversation is really
gross that's all the thing censorship
right and the fact was that they have if
you go like Forbes
there's no advance calls right which are
Klingon pieces which are not coming from
like the leader in an academic field
right that you'll have a religious
conversation what people just whatever
form they believe and that's fine but
there anyone with a a sacred cows I was
because it was about out of Africa and
challenging the recent alum in Africa
that was no no no no that that cannot go
out there and that was just spiders if
you're so rapidly that you know almost
we had sperm that you know kevlar layer
someone has just gone in there and Spike
Denis again off the website and no
explanation and even legally
anthropology said to me like he was
baffled he's like well they can put like
an apology to readers that we've deleted
this article because we think it's it's
no because like one were there nothing
he said that's was like offensive to the
leadership because you're pretty you're
say it's good enough to publish and
there's someone else come along saying
good off there delete it with no
explanation right in the Kennedys need
an apology was actually baffled he said
they've never heard of that happening to
anyone right so think about that part of
what you've experienced we're seeing
with you know what is now coming out of
the shadows with more of like the UFOs
and area 51 and they don't works feels
like there is more acceptance or
responsibility being taken whether it is
individuals that have had these
experiences and are able to verify or
support those claims or it is the the US
government themselves right in releasing
various videos or there are kind of
details what's your take on kind of
these individual stories that we're
hearing and kind of why now some of this
stuff may be coming out and may be
becoming much more accepted and let's
have that yes it's interesting to have
this phenomena now where the last couple
of years me
your media platforms are tackling
subjects like UFOs
also now possible alien materials you
know debris that may come from an
extraterrestrial ship that you know
Woodruff or you know three or four years
ago that you would be seeing articles in
like the New York Times they were
talking about UFOs and you know major
media platforms talking about alien
debris I mean it's quite a ccheng and
doesn't happen it's but even the Harvard
professor who says you know the UFO that
came into the solar system and then
Hannah laughs you know all this stuff is
uh it is getting what I would consider
valid media attention and coverage and I
think it's driven partly by curiosity
and partly by the the fact that it's
hard to ignore it this the fact that
we've got up here the head of the
Harvard astronomy saying there you know
this object could of being a probe you
know an alien probe coming through our
solar system I mean that's astonishing
and again some people saying that he was
doing that just for media attention but
as he pointed out he put it into his
home obscure science and paper and that
he hadn't even put it into the public it
was the journalist someone stumbled on
it I realized that you know that this
would make a good story but you know he
was a serious science paper he wasn't
trying to get any attention or anything
right he just he noticed that it had
enormous characteristics that you know
he was unusually reflective it was
spirit seemed to be spilling in a
certain way which again suggested it was
unusual he had this red coloring it was
covered in love well the things that
meth italic kind of debris and then he
accelerated as it moved out of our solar
system another thing that I wanted
highlight because I find it a very
fascinating what I suspect again could
be that it's some kind of panspermia
machine and one reason I say that is
because it comes when it came through
the solar system
it doesn't just pass by a Jupiter or
something like you know what happened he
entered our solar system basically
between the orbits of Mars and Earth and
across the plane of our solar system
between these two planets the orbits of
these two planets
that's awfully coincidental because Mars
and Earth are the only two planets of
our solar system that are quite
obviously capable of supporting life
right that they have water they have you
know a soil which we now some Martian
soil to grow things in it we think
that's pretty bacterial if I were the
news came out in it really that they're
meeting the definitely to grow there was
the signature for life on Mars we now
have multiple signatures level you up
the methane emissions we know there's
liquid water there's frozen water
there's this say this past soil sampling
with what seemed to be life there's
pictures of what look like lichens on
rocks basically you've got wonder what
mushrooms growing on rocks so isn't it
funny that this object just happens to
pass between the only two players in our
solar system that look like they can
support life so if you were sensing for
life that's basically where you'd want
the probe to go but also if you were
just distributing life you know if this
is something that it's launching out
spores bacterial spores also be a drain
we may even have these raining down on
us from the mission but either way you
know he was willing to point out that
this had characteristics that suggested
it could be an extraterrestrial
technology passing through our services
and that's that's astonishing to see any
to see someone of that caliber saying
that and also goes on to say which is a
key keep quiet any news about is it you
know when we're faint although that we
should have evident among paraphrasing
though we should always have evidence of
things if we find an anomaly we should
recognize the anomaly right and
otherwise how you progress anything
right because unless you're going to say
look this is super weird let's throw
some science at my you know let's work
out what this is if you just say well
it's weird
no everyone look the other way until
it's gone you know to tell you it's not
there right but what the heck is that
so that's what we've been doing with
anomalies right for centuries we'd be
doing well and let's pretend they're not
there and I feel that what we're seeing
now is a sea change in this like we'll
look there's all these anomalies you
know there's what people call UFOs
there's strange things flying for our
solar system there's you know and
abnormalities in the genome there's
always anomalies
hey why don't we turn and face them do
some really good science and find out
what the heck they all are know whether
it's psychic power though yeah whatever
it is you know no matter how straight
we should throw good science to them
until you can even explain them or
explain them away right and that's how
it should work and UFOs now find again
that you are UFOs Eterna I don't I don't
know to use one but you still have to
write I'm not very interested in UFOs
I'll stop myself definitely more you
follow Geist I hate the term you
following it and you follow gee because
if you think about it you wouldn't refer
to an underwater swimming philologist
right but you'd have a marine biologist
yeah we don't know what marine biologist
is and underwater swimming theologist is
an unblinking vague and just sounds
meticulous okay ufologist is the same
really gone unidentified flying object
ology you know what the heck is that
right
a UFO contains 95% explainable phenomena
so misidentifications of airplanes
balloons satellites my stuff I'm not
particularly so since I saw you a foe I
think we're probably a satellite because
most people don't look up alright so
what do they really know about the
things in the sky yeah almost nothing
right
so why I'm interested is where the field
trip has been done so if an organization
like MUFON the mutual UFO network if
they take the cases of the UFOs and they
go through them right they get rid of
all the junk what you end up with is
something like five percent
yeah remain and that these are enormous
phenomena these are abating anomalous
aerial vehicles UAVs and anomalous
aerial phenomena aaps now that's what
I'm interested in these enormous aerial
vehicles and phenomena okay the five
percent more interest in UFOs and while
ufologist as you can see I quite clear
this anomalous phenomena I'm interested
in because anomalous that is an initial
identification - they're no longer
completely unidentified because you can
find structure or propulsion or in
cloaking technology you've now started
getting identification on it right you
know it's a craft at that point yeah
it's not just your night in the sky
what's that oh it's a UFO if you
intervene I was trying away it wasn't a
lake it's got a radar signature it moves
like the
oK you've identified that is a type of
anonymous craft right so now I know what
some a dog weighs are coming from an
attorney now I'm going to work with an
anomalous phenomena that if an object
contains vanish will reappear you know
whether it's a glowing orb which some of
these things are these glowing spheres
which seemed to just disappear in a
change shape right that's anomalous
disappear I can change shape then okay
it's my Chinese balloon right it is a
satellite you know so again I think
people need to attend that the ufology
that really is such a nebulous vague
thing there's a reason why people laugh
at you if you say I saw a UFO now if you
could save to my soul on a normal at
aerial vehicle there port which type of
thing well what's that and ask you why
did you say those well if it was
teleporting you know teleporting around
the sky and that point you've got
someone's attention right in a different
way - I saw allow you - I think it was
you know something what what um what's
your take on I'm kind of intelligent
life outside of Earth so you've got a
lot more kind of study in terms of how
there's been an intersection with that
intelligent life and human origin and
the things that we talked about but
where do you come out is there um you
know multiple colonization's out there
of intelligent life and it looks like
the movies is it something else like
like when you kind of think about the
possibilities where do you have the
highest degree of confidence first I
would probably err on the side of some
of the leading theorists in the field of
said witches they suspect that the
majority of truly advanced you know far
advanced alien civilizations will
probably be post biological
that at some point they will either they
will upload their their awareness their
consciousness their intelligence you
know into these vast silicon networks or
that thing will go extinct and leaving
behind the machines they created right
robots AI whatever so you've got two
different ways in which converges where
you end up with AI okay and technologies
that will be roving space also that if
you're running in advanced SETI program
on an alien world and you're more
advanced than us the entire level really
you're sending out robots we're
exploring Mars with robots we're sending
out robotic probes to look at meteorites
and stuff so most like to counter any
robot right on AI they probably from
multiple worlds I think that the galaxy
is probably full of AI probes from
different civilizations and at this
point it does he's old enough that that
these may I probes could be on every
scene every single star system of the
Milky Way right we can start with that
that's a totally reasonable prediction
because even at sublight speeds there's
been enough billions of years right for
probes to reach every single star system
the galaxy now if you start with that
that contracts a lot of learning the
kind of arguments that people give you
the world
you know oops don't move fast enough to
reserve a home police factor in time
because time is a fixer all those
problems right it doesn't matter how
slow it's going if you can give it like
a million years to reach yeah so I'm
suspect then we're going to mostly be
encountering AI out there and that
there's probably all kinds of
technologies left by past civilizations
and current ones now that there are
likely to be biological intelligence is
still there as well out there and will
they connect with each other I think
it's very likely again if their probes
are bumping up against each other right
there's a good chance that the
civilizations get to know each other and
if they have technologies like they say
more light speed or wormhole travel or
the al-kubra drive this is you know
using warp bubbles swing basically bend
space around the craft instead you're
going to time-travel yeah
so when you're going to those kind of
technologies they're not only closing
the distances but you know that you're
sort of time-traveling as well so
there's a if they develop those exotic
transportation mechanisms there is no
reason why after probes meeting probes
that you can't set up a meeting right so
I think there's a good chance we're
going to find if we go out that and we
contact or if we are in contact from
here that will find there are networks
or alliances or trading you know all
that
is out there well maybe in pockets of
the galaxy or it may be the entire
galaxy is network you know obviously
weak we can only speculate you know we
can absolutely obviously people say that
they've had contact experiences and you
know in that information if you take it
as being valid often it's described as
there's been different kinds of
beginnings that people see now whether
those are psychic experiences or some
echo from our DNA or what they're I
don't know for sure but you know if any
of them are legitimate they tend to
point to there being multiple kinds of
intelligences they're interested in at
each other and us again you know I
recognize that those for most people are
just too speculative but I do think the
contact experiences and what we call
abduction very interesting even if you
don't accept nothing only because you've
said because still got a sailor why is
it that say tens or I don't know maybe
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people around the world are having
experiences where they feel that they're
in the presence of an alien intelligence
and that it's communicating with the
music food telepathy or whatever and
that why is that happening to certain
people you know because in fact is not
contact with another intelligent
shouldn't we want to understand why say
some of our greatest minds like
astronauts
you know people military they decided
why they would be having an experience
like what is going on in the other world
these people really crazy cuz they seem
to go on with their lives working you
know producing for the society and being
productive citizens so it's not mental
illness that we would understand the
mass right because they're totally
mostly fully functional people so we
should want to know you know what's
going on here and let's investigate if
it's a real psychical contact from
another civilization then hey let's try
to pick up the phone and if it's not
shouldn't we be trying to find treatment
for these people right so either way but
I do think that you know that's worth
exploring because it's the only
indicator we have about what kind of
civilizations are out there and that we
have to speculate and say that science
predicts mostly AI but also the
possibility of networked
connections between siblings because it
beats much time and that you know what
they've got the wormhole Tech look just
to clarify on wormhole travel organics
people say that's impossible recently
there's been a study done on could you
use black holes to travel then it turns
out that a knowledge of black hole is
large enough and slow enough rotating
that you can pass through the event
horizon fairly safely without being
ripped apart and they suspect that the
black hole at the center of our galaxy
that Sagittarius one that could be
suitable for going through so where did
that go maybe that takes us to the
island Ramallah galaxy or something we
don't know but could there be
civilizations out there that have
freaking that out whether you can use
stable black holes for travel and
they're able to modify them in some way
that they they can pass through them to
specific locations all that can engineer
these wooden poles is kind of you know
the einstein-rosen bridges through
space-time that they can pull two
locations together they develop the
exotic exotic materials that are
required to open these again we know
that in very speculative theory that
these are possible so let's say another
species has a million years more than us
or ten million years northern us and
they may invent this they're looking
anywhere in the in the galaxy right they
can be on our moon they can be you know
the other side of the galaxy they can be
anywhere so I definitely grow removed in
artificial limitations of human level
thinking from extraterrestrials because
I see all the time people say oh we know
we can't do that or let's get there fast
enough you can't stop thinking like that
I mean because in a million years we
won't have any of the problems that
we're thinking about now right IIIi
think you got a point man you know it
really does come down to the part I like
about this entire conversation is you
are very software in the idea that at
the end of the day we should experiment
with everything we should research
everything and to take you know what in
your words radical ideas and put them
through scientific rigor if we come out
on the other end and they're disproven
then they were simply incorrect thesis
right but if we come out the other end
they end up being valid with supporting
evidence and kind of widely accepted
then they were just simply a new idea
that hadn't been realized yet right so
we the human race is incentivized to
explore all of these radical ideas and
then to ensure that we put it through
that scientific rigor and so although
you probably don't get nearly as much
tension on the work that you're doing as
you'd like you know I think that it's
important work and there should be many
many more people like you that are not
only working on the same types of
problems in thesis but also should have
their own radical ideas to go out and to
explore so Jeff Todd is welcome please
but keep in mind that the TTS a no to
the stars we Tom DeLonge and these guys
from the government working together you
know who are behind with these big
articles they're basically saying the
same sort of thing that I'm saying look
they're saying that there is a genuine
phenomena right behind these crafts and
objects in our skies that they may be
extraterrestrial they're saying they've
got material from these that they think
is engineered not on this world right
they're telling us as well that if you
look at old logbooks his own secret
machines books he claimed that it is
likely we were engineered by
extraterrestrials like all the things
that they're saying during the major
crash which people singing I'm saying
but the major difference right it don't
give any physical evidence I've got
physical to brainy which is being well
tested all right I thought the genetic
anomalies again they being well explored
so I think the irony is because I'm not
very much I because I don't have
millions of dollars to get a PR team
right the people won't know of my work
but I'm actually offering two best of
all right evidence whereas they're
offering quite speculative evidence at
this point yeah we've got pictures of
one looks like a stone and we're going
told that they have these other evidence
yeah but we haven't seen in actually
saying look I'm putting it out there I'm
saying look this isn't you know another
book coming out but I put it out there
ready you know that usually language
existed where there are this is the
material is testing its really
interested you know but it's quite
strange that you know one one is going
the New York Times because if who is and
better evidence is virtually unknown
because I'm not as famous and they don't
have
the finances to pay a PR team to put
this in the New York Times basically for
sure well look at and I think that again
it comes down to you've got so many
people who are all hitting on the same
thing or around the same thing that you
know eventually we end up making a
breakthrough you know and in my personal
opinion you know what you said earlier
just rings so true there are two
existential questions that every single
human in their lifetime will ask the
first is is there life after death or is
there some sort of you know environment
after death and the second is are we
alone are we the only intelligent
lifeform here or are there others and I
think that the work that you're doing to
focus on that ladder is important and
frankly look if you or somebody else is
able to concretely establish that there
is intelligent life somewhere else
outside of Earth it'll be one of the
greatest scientific breakthroughs of our
life right and so it's only crazy and
wild and kind of taboo until it's proven
to be true right nifty roger bannister
no no one broke the four-minute mile and
then once one person did it everyone did
and they take one scientific kind of
discovery with full you know
documentation and kind of passing up the
scientific rigor and all of a sudden it
will be a known fact that yes there is
other intelligence out there we are not
alone and that will open up a world of
possibilities and frankly capital that
will be invested to what to go explore
and ride out more so you know keep going
thank you yeah and I've upsetting with
new partners with being at this stage
you know I think they may find their
name on one of the biggest discoveries
in human history because I've not as yet
had anyone being able to explain away
the evidence put it that way there's you
know if the scientists want to try to
have more scientists look at what I'm
saying if they can find their holes
great right but if they can't or they
validate it then hey this is a paradigm
change
then for sure where can people go find
more of your work either the books or
anything else that they you're working
on
sure I have three websites bruce fenton
info and ancient news net and I
basically let's find me on Facebook on
Twitter I'm not currently as well I'm a
recurring guest expert speaker on
ancient aliens on the History Channel
thankfully terms giorgio kind of less my
work and he's asked that I come on so
I'm now going on there and I should be a
contact in the desert next year 2020 to
present there so people couldn't contact
me you know Twitter is my most active
but they they can contact me for my
websites Facebook you know clapping for
that guided alright Bruce listen I
really appreciate you taking the time we
recorded from was two hours so I know
your time is valuable and I just
appreciate you coming on in kind of
talking through a lot of this stuff you
know there's a lot of folks who we're
interested from hearing from you so
thanks so much and as you continue your
work we'll have to do this again in the
future great thank you very much and I
really appreciate you know taking the
time and that you've to the time to look
at some of the the papers I sent you and
everything so I'm really everyone please
he brought me all it's been really good
chat thank you everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us to take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
home page scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain